Happy new year?
Guys that’s in like a week.
Oh right, I’m on the Julian Calendar.
Good day everyone, Julian here for DNews.
Have you ever wondered why the calendar is
the way it is?
What drove us in the western world to have
a 365 day year?
Turns out it’s an interplay between astronomy,
religion, and history.
The calendar we use right now is the Gregorian
calendar, so named because it was implemented
by Pope Gregory the thirteenth in 1582.
Why would the pope be interested in the calendar?
[[*RE-TRACKED on 12/18 - Cars have faces shoot*]]Well
Easter was traditionally supposed to fall
on the Sunday after the first full moon after
the spring equinox, March 21st, but it had
started slipping later and later behind the
solar event.
Gregory was worried they were missing Christ’s
rebirthday, so he commissioned italian scientist
Aloysius Lilius to fix it and make sure they
were on Jesus’ good side.
When they made the switch, the catholic world
jumped forward a full 10 days.
And you thought daylight savings was bad.
Many non-catholic countries wouldn’t adopt
the Gregorian calendar for hundreds of years
still.
Russia switched after their October revolution
in 1917, which under the new system, technically
began in November.
The reason the Gregorian Calendar is more
accurate with our solar cycle is because it
changed how we approached leap years.
It still has a leap year every 4 years, like
the Julian Calendar, except for years that
are divisible by 100, except except for years
that are divisible by 400.
So 2000 was a leap year, but 2100 will not
be.
Why this wonky system for leap years?
As it turns out, our revolution around the
sun is not a perfect 365 days, but 365 days,
5 hours, 48 minutes and 46 seconds.
Before Julius Caesar became emperor the calendar
was all over the place, literally being manipulated
by the roman high priest for political reasons.
Sometimes years were lengthened to keep allies
in office, sometimes they were shortened to
kick rivals out quicker.
Julius Caesar put a stop to that by standardizing
the Julian calendar.
Introduced in 45 BCE, or what to the romans
was 709 as they counted years from the founding
of the city of Rome.
His calendar had 365 days every year with
an extra day every 4.
It still made the average year length 11 minutes
and 14 seconds too long, but that wouldn’t
be evident until hundreds of years passed.
To honor him for reforming the calendar, the
roman senate changed the name of Caesar's
birth month to July.
They’d honor him again a year later by murdering
him on the infamous ides of March
I always wondered, if Caesar could change
the calendar willy nilly, why didn’t he
just get rid of March?
Way to drop the ball, Caesar.
The reason we’re in the year 2015 though
and not 2768 is because in 525 Christian Monk
Dionysius Exiguus determined that Jesus was
born in the roman year 753, and started counting
over again from there.
Because of him we get the terms BC for before
Christ, and AD, which does not stand for After
Death but actually Anno Domini, which in Latin
means “The Year of Our Lord.”
In the academic and scientific communities,
to keep things neutral and welcoming to people
of all faiths, you’ll often see the terms
BCE and CE for Before Common Era and Common
Era.
Of course the Gregorian Calendar is far from
the only calendar in use around the world
today.
Many calendars from cultures with less pronounced
seasons actually rely on the cycles of the
moon instead of the Sun.
But for predicting the change of seasons,
equinoxes, solstices, and when certain constellations
will be visible, the Gregorian is the one
we prefer for its regularity.
At least until 4909, when it’ll be a day
ahead.
If you already blew it on your new years resolution,
I’d say switch to the Julian calendar and
try again next week.
But first check out Catie’s video on what
you did wrong over here.
I’ve never lived by a different calendar
but I’m sure a lot of you out there watching
do.
What’s it like going by a system where the
seasons aren’t the same dates each year?
Do you use the gregorian calendar too?
Let us know in the comments, and I’ll see
you next time on DNews.